cybersecurity is a unique challenge
today because one we are so utterly
dependent upon our digital
communications and our digital control
of things and so it's going to become
ever more essential that we have the
ability to provide security that we're
confident in the challenge is if we were
against dr. know or mr. big in a cave
somewhere you could understand the
threat and you could sort of limit the
threat and the threat would have a
predictable limitation and what they
could do they'd have to pick an avenue
of approach and they'd have to go at
that Avenue of approach because they
can't do all things at all times
the problem with cybersecurity that's
not the threat there are some entities
like that there's some state sponsored
entities that are focused on certain
things but the barrier to entry into the
cyber world is very low you can get in
your basement in your boxer shorts and
you can have a computer and you can get
into the game and it's sort of the idea
of 10,000 monkeys typing on 10,000
keyboards somebody's going to create a
cyber security challenge and so and it's
constantly morphing and adapting whereas
the cyber security requirement is to
protect things so you essentially have
to protect everything that you value all
the time
the people who want to attack that can
attack at their choosing wherever they
want and constantly change their attacks
constantly just like water goes against
a dam it just goes until it finds the
weakest point at some point something
happens technology changes human error
technological glitch or whatever there's
a good likelihood that they'll get in
and so if you think about the
cybersecurity problem the first thing I
don't think will work is the Maginot
Line
you know the Maginot Line was created by
the French in the 1930s to prevent the
Germans from doing a repeat of the First
World War and invading France from
Germany people think of it now is the
stupidest thing ever built but it's not
really correct because the Maginot Line
actually worked the Germans did not
invade across the German French border
now the fact is they went through
Belgium they still got into France and
conquered France in the summer 1940 so I
think the lesson to be learned is there
have to be defensive things set up as
best
we can for cybersecurity but it's gonna
have to be this constantly adapting
constantly morphing defense-in-depth
with some offense to with going out and
figuring out where the threats are
arising and that that defense in depth
means that you can't have one line the
government can't put a big wall up and
everybody hides behind it nor do we want
each organization each commercial firm
or government organization to be an
island unto themselves just hoping that
they're not the weakest wildebeest in
the herd and that the Lions will get
somebody else what we really need is all
those entities to be links so they
constantly learn from one another if one
suffers a breach everyone has to learn
from it right now the challenge is
people are loath to share that
information one because commercially
they might be hurt by reputation also
they're afraid that the more you share
the more you have the event the
possibility of your little island is not
completely separated your moat around it
has got linkages across it and and you
can be opened up more but we're gonna
have to get a network to defense where
every time something happens and we
learn from it the entire network learns
immediately we're gonna have to have
that kind of speed because there will be
breaches there will be mistakes but the
organiz organized UM's got to learn it's
gonna have to be a lot like the human
immune system the human immune system is
extraordinary because about 10,000 times
a day it gets attacked by something that
could hurt the human body but as it
responds and it sends out you know and
antibodies to it it does it and it
learns from that and so if it has a
breach one time it actually builds up
antibodies against that challenge and
has them at the ready for the next time
that's how we build up immunity to
things and I think the human immune
system is the way our cyber defense is
going to have to be which means it it
has to be integrated
you